five-minute ER all righty let's go with
D for and let's go with this and want to
learn more about the Trump of ski and I
want to take that and try and show that
this pond rule is not purposeful let's
see if I could do that I'm going to play
a bit more solid with this move instead
of coming out here I want to make sure I
maintain control over this pond and to
play Bishop here I haven't decided if i
want to play pawn to c4 hmm let's get
this in maybe I do want to do this move
ah interesting ok well get my nights out
be looking into uh what am I gonna be
looking into let's put pressure on this
Center a little bit i want to kick this
Bishop back ok we're not having that so
it's gonna come over here back up keep
the check I just block now what has
opened up I guess there's this pawn push
breaking up my center and I actually do
not have this move available oh now
that's interesting because that was the
advantage that black had having the
bishop pair and now it's been given up
the King side is a problem well ok so
it's a bit weak in double ponds but I
don't know if that was a good decision
let's see ok so i have to show an
advantage if there's really an advantage
can I just throw my night here and go
after the bishop let's just castle I'm
four I'm foreseeing pressure on the
queenside
interesting now I'm foreseeing pressure
on the c.c pond I get this advance in or
even a 4 there's a couple moves I could
have available to me also whoa now
that's pretty nuts right there I think
that loses a pond though Bishop here f5
otherwise i get the c6 pun if Bishop
here pond push Bishop Back the Night
Moves then Queen to f3 hits at both of
these squares and try that I think hang
on you just get out of this pin let's do
this first okay let's come back now that
I've provoked this Queen f3 I'll come
with an additional point to be here
although Queen f3 could be okay well the
night has to go to this square okay it's
gone they're clean here hmm
Queen f3 queen d 5 e 4 pawn takes pawn
takes let me try that time issue less
then well my opponent has a minute plus
on me so I'm netting this pond or am i
or am i or am I night for Bishop takes
pawn would be met with night h4 okay so
glad i didn't do that and before it's
too late I should really challenge this
pond interesting very interesting Bishop
here followed by a pawn push and upon
capture or something or maybe bring my
night into this square this is tricky
pretty tricky I really don't want to
take here i would rather okay that
capture occur and let's go with this I
got to go quicker if there's an
advantage i'm trying to make it be this
pawn right here I'm going to take I
don't want this rope to get to be too so
easily so let's do this and I want to
just throw my knight in to see five and
take here the Queen gets active but
hopefully this could work you know the
Queen's really going to get active maybe
I shouldn't have allowed that okay I
think just double up double those rooks
let's do it here first if Queen B to I
could throw my rock on a five rook
seized up to see to was probably a bit
more solid so but this is a just
something that really can't be ignored
can
I mean it checking a position Queen c4
let's go here pin that night and then I
think I could just take that next ok
that Knights pinned Queen trade let's
play here I'd like to get the Queen's
off the board I think this pond could
fall in a position where there aren't
any Queens so I really just want to get
rid of the most active black piece here
all right we're gonna probably going to
dance a little bit here with some checks
all right a little dancing going on now
that I'm okay with that because i think
i could get that pond okay watch out for
the tricky Forks I'm not seeing where
the forks are with that last move what
does black have to watch out for watch
out for seventh-ranked issues the king
could be cut off and let's let's kind of
box them out h5 I just play here let's
didn't do it anyhow there might be a
knight move there maybe I keep my rook I
think it's the more active could do this
pond advanced I'm not seeing a clear win
I see small improvements I community
making this not being one of them I
thought it was but it gives the night DF
foursquare what about rook right here
maybe my rook could be doing something
else
and all right where are the tricks here
let me do this trade nights it's
actually forced is otherwise I'm getting
this or something ooh okay active row
keep the active r up there take here
trade its trade trade trade trade or I
get another pond or do I I want to just
defend f oh man that's a good move
that's a really good move okay i have a
check and then i could grab c6 for a
second I thought the rib plate here
wanna get active I want to be able to
defend my f2 pond just can't be easy the
rooks are getting active now getting
active with those rooks all right I want
to maybe give a check to the king or
something right here and then push this
pawn just a little bit i have f to
covered
maybe I should get my king involved King
f3 would be bad just thinking King f3
don't do that don't you dare do that I
could try this I could give up f2 cuz i
get on some other pieces back i'm gonna
take enough to let stake here I get um I
get a bunch of pawns how do you win this
king and pawn in game well I don't think
it should be too too bad let's just play
here and then King position is the last
thing King position could actually go
for a little walk right over here and
then push that pawn away I rook is a
cutting the black king off and then this
one could just push away watch out for a
stalemate no stalemate okay interesting
middle game right there I thought I had
a lot of pressure and then I thought I
was winning upon
and I wasn't winning upon and let me
gather my thoughts here I really didn't
know I I thought I was good I thought I
was doing good but I wasn't able to show
it earlier on I thought I should have
been able to but there was some good
resistance put up there by a good player
so let's sing here packing up and
looking at it from blacks perspective
I'm not so sure about the the h6 move
maybe just d5 I think the popular move
the most typical mozar efore in d5 I
really don't know about h6 that's just
one quick thing and I'm not so sure
about the decision to run with right
here with Bishop takes Knight however I
think that c5 is a good move I think c5
is um so what is what's the scoop with
c5 c5 opens the position up the bishop
hair and I don't have this move are no
no wait a second i do have that
available i do have bad available c5 i
would have this move available i was
thinking Queen takes can't be played
because the night is pinned but i would
have bishop check and I pick off the
Queen so I there is a response to c5 so
I was mistaken during the game with my
thought process there the night is able
to reposition to this square and I'm not
winning upon here I did a lot of I
consumed a lot of time on that one but
uh at the end of it if I if I took this
poem again there'd be Bishop Bishop
takes pawn is met with night h4 so let's
not do that and what's the scoop here
yeah I don't know I mean I have pressure
on this pond so is there some way to get
rid of that seep on because that's
that's a big problem isn't it how can
you get rid of that seep on it's kind of
tough maybe maybe pushing b5 is not a
good idea because it is making it
backwards maybe there's a more solid
approach like Knight b6 and then Bishop
to e6 I think that turns out to be a
problem having an isolated sepan so
maybe that's a move that could go you
know you could go without playing that
b5 move not sure it would seem that way
it seemed that there's going to be
something better to be doing and that
because it does turn out to be a problem
yeah there's no structural damage on the
white end but this this turns out to be
a target so i don't know i don't know
about be five in the earlier age six
move but there was clearly a lot of
resistance put up throughout the whole
game and even into the end game because
of the the pressure that maybe could be
placed on f2 which was not too far off i
did have to make sure i got my rook in a
position to guard it on the f file here
I'm up upon in this spot but as soon as
your Brooks start getting active one pig
on the second and then I need to have
this rook around to defend like that but
anyhow good resistance being down that
pond for so long right there and I did
have to watch out for the little tricks
along the way with for sure I had to
watch out for those tricks the night eh
for move in particular